des gratteurs match gamma bonjour je
vous présente comment mathieu gamme à
votre fonction exacte
bonjour monsieur livory je suis porte
parole du mouvement en marche j'ai un
marcheur historique peut être le premier
en martinique et donc voilà c'est comme
ça qu'il faut me présenter donc vous
êtes toujours porte parole de la
république en marche c'est ça je le des
porte paroles ou les porte parole
officiels non je pense que le référent
du mouvement marche en martinique si
monsieur copette et que je suis le porte
parole comme l'avait décidé le
coordinateur à l'époque max dubois
pourquoi on a l'impression qu'il ya une
lutte de pouvoir au sein de
lrm en martinique il y a plusieurs quand
éric copette dernière choumicha de
lordinot daniel robin et puis vous c'est
une bonne question ça serait bien de
poser aux autres la même question
personnellement je me suis engagé auprès
de d'emmanuel macro mois de juin 2016
donc donc je ne sais pas je pense qu'il
ya un intérêt pour chacun pour chacun de
ces deux c'est de ces personnes chacune
de ces personnes de se revendiquer en
marche si c'est des gens qui vont vers
le projet présidentiel en marchant j'ai
dit que c'était d'abord le projet du
candidat
s'ils vont vers ce projet parce que ça
leur plaît moi j'ai envie de dire
pourquoi pas mais il faut respecter une
certaine organisation celle qui est en
place avant qu'il n'y ait des précisions
à dire sa part été fait je qu'ils aient
à derrière maintenant qu'ils n'ont pas
respectées l'organisation qui était déjà
fait bien vous savez quand vous arrivez
dans une structure et que vous vous auto
proclamés
je sais pas candidat pour amant mais ils
ont eu d'accord de paris mais quels
accords de paris la seule le
coordinateur antilles guyane max dubois
qui n'est plus en marche alors à l'heure
où je vous parle avait décidé d'une
réorganisation en nommant monsieur copé
est référent et en me nommant porte
parole donc
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut faire
preuve de bienveillance à tous égards
dans plusieurs camps qui ne se parlent
pas aujourd'hui vous savez quand
emmanuel macron est reparti de
martinique il on a fait une réunion de
stratégie politique et il a dit à ses
conseillers
je veux un comité politique large et
surtout varié
je veux des gens de diffuser différentes
mouvances et qui ça allait de nos
peuples à hao ppm en passant par le mime
et le rdr
vous avez vu que ça s'est pas passé
comme ça mais c'est ce que vous voulez
c'est ce que voulait manu et le
maquereau après son séjour en martinique
et donc on n'a pas réussi à faire ça
parce que parce que parce que la
convoitise des grandes et je pense que
bon on a pas on est en marche et une
start up politique j'ai envie de dire et
on a peut-être fait preuve de naïveté et
on n'a pas su vaincre à l'opportunisme
des uns et des autres de l'opportuniste
rêve que vous dites oui opportunisme
politique
emmanuel macron a dit en ce qui
concernait le ps quand marche ne serait
pas une recyclerie du ps et ben moi je
vous dis ce matin quand on sera pas une
recyclerie du ppm non plus quelle forme
prendra la prépublication martiniquais
lors
après l'élection du président dimanche
vous souhaitez être à la tête du
mouvement qui peut se structurer ici en
martinique
je pense quand résolument il faut se
tourner vers des modes de construction
démocratique
c'était un mouvement vous avez vu tout
le la polémique qui a été fait ici parce
que justement on a peut-être grandi trop
vite on ne croyait pas emmanuel macron
des parents jusqu'à ce qu'il vienne
jusqu'à ce que le travail soit fait par
la base du militant et donc moi ce que
j'ai fait parvenir comme comme ideo au
qg de paris c'est qu'il fallait qu'on
aille vers une organisation démocratique
avec des élections des adhérents est
comme ça ben les choses seront réglées
d'accord le vote macro on va avancer
dans nos de l'intérieur de votre mac
crois donc toucher la martinique et
cette vague a fait des dégâts dans un
parti le bpm et en particulier trois
démissions en une nuit dimanche après
l'élection quel regard jetez vous sur ce
fait exactement
alors vous savez moi je suis pour la
bienveillance en politique donc ma
première réaction c'est à dire ben que
c'est une bonne chose parce que si ces
gens là ne se sentait pas à l'aise dans
leur parti d'origine ainsi bien qu'il
crée quelque chose qui leur qui leur
ressemblent donc dont ça c'est la
première chose et puis ça ça va
peut-être créer une participer à la
vitalité démocratique du pays
c'est sur cette même langue que vous
traitiez tout à l'heure d'opportunistes
c'est exact mais on parle des mêmes
personnes exactement est par contre je
suis heureux que c'est ces gens là est
accepté de prendre le risque
alors ça a été un risque modéré parce
qu'ils ont surfé sur la vague en marche
avant de se lancer
ils se sont pas lancés d'un coup d'un
seul mais mais il s'est dit c'est une
très bonne chose que le paysage soir
composé remodelé et je vois ça d'un bon
oeil
c'est la fin des partis traditionnels
savez c'est toujours très dangereux de
faire des déclarations péremptoires mais
ce que ce qui est manuel macron à
trouver c'est que c'est que dans la vie
en fait tout est possible et moi c'est
ce que je retiens
on est dans on était dans un système
de blocage de clivage gauche droite
quand ils en parlaient même si on veut
centaine en disant voilà maintenant la
gauche et la droite c'est fini le
clivage entre réformateurs et
conservateurs beaucoup rigolé beaucoup
d'observateurs rigoler en disant mais
qu'est ce qu'il raconte maintenant il
est président et je pense qu'il va y va
incarner
ben justement cette ce changement de
donne on devrait connaître très
prochainement les noms des candidats
estampillés l et r e m pour les
législatives les postulants se
bousculent en martinique également comme
dans l'hexagone ben le processus a été
très clair dès le départ il fallait
candidater à une certaine époque il
fallait
saumon très investi et
ensuite on fait aussi de la politique on
peut toujours faire acte de candidature
aujourd'hui au ballon c'est terminé
c'est terminé depuis belle lurette mais
maintenant il ya une commission
d'investiture qui est présidée par
monsieur delevoye qui est un grand
monsieur de la politique française
il a été un président de l'association
des maires et donc moi j'ai toute
confiance dans la commission
d'investiture fera son job elle elle
donnera les investitures aux personnes
qu'elle estime digne de représenter le
mouvement et et voilà on il faut faire
confiance à la commission d'investiture
sait par exemple que justin pamphile a
fait acte de candidature pour la
circonscription nord que bruno nast
eurasie roues le député sortant a lui
aussi fait acte de candidature est ce
qu'on risque pas de se retrouver avec
plusieurs candidats estampillés lrm sur
une même circonscription je ne sais pas
mais vous savez le l'investiture en
marche elle est comment dire
c'est une un engagement du candidat s'il
est élu à entrer dans la démarche
présidentielle dans le projet
présidentiel dans la majorité
présidentielle
donc je ne sais pas quel choix fera pour
la circonscription du nord la commission
d'investiture mais je rappelle une chose
monsieur pamphile il s'est engagé très
tôt
pour emmanuel macron monsieur à 0,6 il
ya et j'en profite pour remercier tous
les maires qui m'ont prêté leur concours
madame d'ulysse petit messieurs
attendent à jeanne rose monsieur
christian rafa c'est des gens qui très
tôt on donnait m'ont donné leur
parrainage pour emmanuel macron et qui
vont faire en sorte que dans leur
commune qu emmanuel macron certains
peuvent donc donc on verra bien ce que
dit la commission d'investiture mais de
toute façon moi j'ai confiance dans les
institutions de mon parti emmanuel
macron veut organiser les assises de
l'outre-mer comment a germé cette idée
alors cette idée elle a germé
en collaboration avec le pôle outremer
qui réfléchissaient qui a réfléchi dès
le mois de décembre aux programmes des
manuels macron l'idée c'était quand
emmanuel macron et était ici on lui a
expliqué les choses on lui a dit écoutez
manuel nous antillais
on nous a promis beaucoup de choses
maintenant l'idée ce serait peut-être de
mettre en responsabilité les élus locaux
et de leur dire on a des moyens humains
techniques intellectuelle financiers
pour aider des projets ultramarins
présenter les nous et on vous aidera
en 2009 nicolas sarkozy alors président
avait mis en place aussi les états
généraux de des outre-mer n'y a rien de
neuf
ben la différence entre emmanuel macron
et nicolas sarkozy sait que emmanuel
macron il alla il a la culture du projet
et donc ça veut dire qu'il tire des
enseignements
il a la culture du projet oui monsieur
du bourru sable ou même et vernis
nicolas sarkozy l'avait là où l'on fait
des bilans il fait des points d'étape
c'est quand il mène un projet bien il
est il écrit il le mûri on pose des
jalons
on vérifie on on observe ce qu'on
appelle en gestion de projet les
stakeholders les parties prenantes
donc on emmanuel macro s'il s'engage sur
un projet pour le l'outre-mer comme la
croissance bleue
c'est quelque chose qui lui a été
proposé quand il était ici moi j'ai fait
appel à un expert qui s'appelle marouane
belle dame qui a travaillé par exemple à
la sem martinique et on lui a fait tenir
un projet qui s'appelle guadeloupe
martinique durable il s'en est inspiré
pour l' agence française de la
biodiversité qui va s'installer en outre
mer pour la conférence sur la
biodiversité
donc voilà le job est fait moi j'ai
confiance dans ces c'est pas n'importe
qui qu'on a élu sa devrai ces états
généraux se devrait se tenir quand
exactement
ben en fait il a promis que c'était dans
les 100 premiers jours
durant les 100 premiers jours de sa
présidence donc j'ai jamais aucune
crainte sur le fait que ça se fera très
rapidement
pensez vous qu'ils livrent un ministre
issu des outre-mer on parle beaucoup des
riches à l'us le président de la région
guadeloupe
ary chalus s'il est positionné lui aussi
très tôt pour emmanuel macron ya thierry
robert aussi qui c'est qui qui a fait le
travail qui a notamment à mon sens
ramener françois mais ouvert vers
emmanuel macron la l'énorme différence
est que entre les deux c'est que thierry
robert il a participé activement à
l'écriture du programme pour l'outre-mer
donc ça veut dire qu'il a en tête les
contingences techniques administratives
et autres de ce programme là et donc
voilà mais ainsi mathieu gamma porte
parole dans de la république marche
arcady est terminée bonne journée à
notre rang sur notre antenne
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
les greta tête